the annual summerlin patriotic parade is
back in full form for the first time
since the pandemic started in 2020. oh
yeah brian and i and jc and mercedes we
won't be on floats this year we'll be
back on the ground now volunteers are
putting the finishing touches on the new
on the floats and oh my gosh we're
getting so excited mary jane belliesa is
live this morning from trails park in
summerlin to tell us more about all the
festivities mary jane
sherry good morning i don't know if you
guys can tell but we are making it snow
out here we are on the frozen float so
it's only right you know that we have
the snow come in and of course i'm
wearing blue too so i guess you can say
i'm princess elsa anna for today and
joining me brian early this morning is
tommy perella with the summerlin council
and tommy you know you just have some
wonderful floats here that you guys have
been working so hard to get through
we're on frozen right now i mean i'm
sure this is a kids favorite absolutely
we do have our patriotic floats and we
want to make sure we honor our
veterans and our military and we have a
patriotic presence but we do incorporate
pop culture we've got frozen what's been
popular this year we have in kanto which
is new so we definitely have that
component and then we have entries from
four professional sports teams as well
so we try to have a diverse uh
entries or 70 entries total and we want
to appeal to the whole family and just
have it be a nice time for the family
and the community to celebrate together
early on the 4th and it's awesome
because you know this parade is free
families and kids of all ages can come
out and enjoy it
where are you guys hosting it so it
starts at hill center
drive and hill point that's the
beginning of the parade route and it
continues about a mile it's between the
trails community center and the
summerlin library and it's both sides of
the street so there's plenty of
opportunity to set up anywhere find the
shade along the side wear sunscreen
drink water um but be prepared give
yourself a little time to park and get
in your spot and just enjoy the the
morning and
all the patriotic
patriotic experience that we've provided
tommy thank you so much
we're getting soap bubbles in our mouth
here right now from all of the snow
that's supposed to be making its way
through reporting live mary jane valeza
live local now